[Musique]
il était une fois une petite fille qui
peinait à trouver sa place dans le monde
elle était rêveuse solitaire est timide
et avait ce sentiment d'être
transparente aux yeux de ceux qui
l'entouraient elle était différente
oui différentes et aux rares personnes à
qui à l'accord dès sa confiance
elle disait qu'elle venait de la lune et
avait été envoyé sur terre pour y
accomplir une mission elle passait le
plus clair de son temps chez sa grand
mère dans une grande maison remplie de
vieux objets de souvenir l'an passé
c'est là qu'un jour elle vit un vieux
livres de compte qu elle ouvrit sans se
douter que cette découverte allait
changer sa vie à jamais
cette petite fille c'est moi
et si je suis là devant vous aujourd'hui
pour vous raconter cette histoire c'est
parce que les livres m'ont sauvé oui
sauver le mode et pas trop fort les
livres m'ont bercé ils ont été un abri
pour moi ils m'ont donné ce vaste et
libérateur sentiment de pouvoir écarter
mais elle un grand sentiment de liberté
particulièrement à l'adolescence cet âge
délicat où l'on cherche à briser ces
entraves familiale où on cherche un sens
à sa vie ou tel un funambule entre
l'enfance et l'âge adulte on oscille on
cherche à sortir de sa chrysalide un
souvenir ressurgi dans ma mémoire je
dois avoir 13 ou 14 ans je jette mon
dévolu sur un livre d'asnières nos les
armoires vides
je dévore le livre d'une traite et quand
je leur ferme
c'est un détonateur dans ma vie denise
cette héroïne poisseuse cette fille
cachottière c'est moi je n'ai plus le
sentiment d'être une mauvaise fille pour
mes parents je me sens moins coupable
j'ai moins honte de celle que je suis
marcel proust écrit que la lecture dans
nos vies et salutaire parce qu'elle nous
ouvre au fond de nous les portes sans
elle nous n'aurions pas pu pénétrer à
l'intérieur de ses portes pour découvrir
qu'ils nous sommes et oui je crois que
c'est ça exactement ça oh il y à mille
et une bonnes raisons de lire on peut
lire pour apprendre bien sûr lire pour
se divertir
lire pour s'évader se ressourcer lire
pour se souvenir lire pour oublier que
l'on va mourir
et parce que les livres et l'art ont
toujours tenu une place très
particulière très prépondérante dans ma
petite géologie intime parce qu'ils
m'ont nourri et parce qu'ils ont fait la
femme que je suis devant vous imparfaite
certes avec ses fragilités mais mû par
cette irrépressible désir d'avoir une
vie belle et de développer chez les
autres cette capacité à rêver en grand
être bibliothécaire a été naturel comme
une évidence pour moi
bibliothécaire une profession plutôt
méconnu objet de nombreux stéréotypes
non les bibliothécaires ne sont pas
toutes des femmes que 10 des vieilles
filles passablement névrosés qui vous
regardent d'un air sévère dès que vous
faites un peu de bruit et dont le seul
mot se résumerait à vous fait trop de
bruit
les livres ne sont pas contents en
réalité
certes nous sommes discrets et peu
présents sous les feux de la rampe
à une exception près toutefois pendant
les périodes de canicule avez vous
constaté pendant les périodes de
canicule que les médias exhorte les
personnes les plus fragiles à pousser la
porte des bibliothèques pour se mettre
au frais je tiens à préciser que les
bibliothèques n'ont pas toutes la
climatisation d'ailleurs bref certains
d'entre vous dans 7 salles peuvent peut
être se dire oui pour les bibliothèques
d'accord mais à l'ère de la des mariés
tête de la dématérialisation des
supports et du web 2.0
quelle est leur utilité et bien
justement savez vous que les
bibliothèques constitue le premier
équipement culturel en france elle jeu
donc un rôle majeur dans la culture et
le savoir mais aussi dans l'émancipation
de la personne on pourrait presque dire
que le slogan des bibliothèques pour
reprendre un slogan bien connu d'une
multinationale que vous reconnaîtrez
aisément pourrait être venez comme vous
êtes effectivement militons au quotidien
pour une société inclusive où chacun à
sa place
vous saviez ya fort longtemps quand j'ai
débuté ma carrière enfin fort longtemps
une quinzaine d'années j'étais à la
banque de prêt d'une bibliothèque de
l'agglomération d'orléans il pleuvait
beaucoup
un petit garçon est entré pour rendre
ses livres et son papa attendaient
dehors sous la pluie ça m'a interpellé
je suis sorti je suis allé le voir et je
lui ai dit mais monsieur entrez entrez
vous mettre à l'abri il m'a montré ses
mains je m'en souviendrai toute ma vie
et m'a dit regardez mes mains ce sont
celles d'un ouvrier
je n'ai pas ma place dans votre monde
ses mots m'ont marqué au fer rouge
je ne les ai jamais oublié et c'est pour
cette raison là que je me suis dit les
bibliothèques sont accessibles à tous
sans distinction et ne sera pas que des
mots mais je vais le faire en actes les
bibliothèques au 21e siècle ce sont des
incubateurs chaque bibliothèque est
unique
porté par l'inventivité et la créativité
des bibliothécaires qui composent
l'équipe à la ferté-saint-aubin où j'ai
posé mes vas-y où j'ai posé mes valises
il ya trois ans nous avons fait ce pari
un peu fou de faire des bibliothécaires
les ambassadeurs du bien-être et du
développement relationnel pour une vie
plus durable est meilleur un projet
ambitieux mais qui fonctionne
grâce à l'énergie des thérapeutes que
nous invitons dans le cadre d'ateliers
de bien-être et de développement
personnel et grâce aussi à des
animations à des ateliers que nous avons
fabriquer nous mêmes que nous avons rêvé
pensées et mises en place et parce que
des actes et par ceux expérimentés les
choses c'est mieux juste que de les dire
comme ça je vais vous invitez maintenant
à vivre une expérience de sieste
poétique musicale accompagnée au
violoncelle
nous allons accueillir karine sur scène
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous allez pouvoir vous installer
confortablement dans votre fauteuil
les deux pieds bien ancrés au sol
fermez les yeux et vous laisser porter
par cette expérience sensorielle
il n'y a rien entre nous il n'y a
personne
il n'y a en août une attente sans
couleur et sans forme elle est en nous
comme de l'air mélangé à de l'air c'est
avec la fin de l'enfance que la tante a
commencé on fait quelques pas hors de
l'enfance puis très vite s'arrête on
attend on attend jusqu'à ce que la tente
se délivre d'elle même l'amour comment
cela dans les fonds du désert il est
invisible dans ses débuts indiscernable
dans son visage
d'abord on ne voit rien on voit qu'il
avance c'est tout
il avance vers lui même vers son propre
couronnement ainsi vous avez vu avancer
dans la poussière d'été toute légère
dans votre robe toute blanche celle
qu'on aime on la voit s'avancer toute
nue elle est dans une robe claire et
pourtant elle est nue comme une étoile
au point du jour à vous voir une
clairière s'ouvrait dans mes yeux
à voir cette robe blanche toute blanche
comme du ciel bleu
avec le regard simple revient la force
pure dans le moulin de ma solitude vous
entriez comme l'aurore vous avanciez
comme le feu vous alliez dans mon âme
comme un fleuve en crue et vos reer
inondait toutes mes terres quand je
rentrais en moi je ne me retrouvais rien
là où tout était sombre un grand soleil
tournait
là où tout était mort une petite source
danser il n'y a pas de connaissance en
dehors de l'amour il y a dans l'amour
que de l'inconnaissable je vous
reconnais c'est vous étiez celle qui
dort tout au fond du printemps sous les
feuillages jamais éteinte du rêve je
vous devine est depuis longtemps déjà
dans la fraîcheur d'une promenade dans
le bonheur des grands livres ou dans la
faiblesse d'un silence vous étiez
l'espérance de grandes choses
vous étiez la beauté de chaque jour vous
étiez l'avis même du froid c'est de vos
robes aux trembles et de vous rires vous
enleviez la sagesse qui est pire que la
mort vous de vous me donniez la fièvre
qui est la vraie fonte et du temps à
passer des jours ont brûlé aucune cendre
sur le seuil
comme si vous n'aviez jamais quitté
cette petite robe de fête l'amour nous
donnait toujours un pur visage d'enfance
soufflant l'ombre sur notre est comme si
le temps n'était rien comme si l'amour
était tous vous étiez comme un moineau
sautillant dans mon coeur
j'apprenais les manière des grands
arbres
le moindre écart et vous vous envoyer
jusqu'à ses ciels en vous inaccessible
et puis vous êtes parti ce n'était pas
trahir
c'était suivre le même chemin on vous
simple dans ces détours vous emportez
avec vous la petite robe de neige
elle ne danse est plus dans ma vie elle
ne tournait plus dans mes rêves
elle flottait sous mes paupières lorsque
je les ferme est pour m'endormir juste
là entre l'oeil et le monde qui n'a pas
connu l'absence ne sais rien de l'amour
qui a connu l'absence a pris
connaissance de son néant
c'est une connaissance calme
c'est une lumière douce dans les fin de
l'été à la tombée de l'enfance avec la
fin de l'amour apparaissent les rois
mages la mélancolie le silence et la
joie ils avancent lentement dans l'herbe
le il emmène avec une couronne dhombres
une larme d'or ils viennent de l'enfance
il pénètre dans l'âme lentement jour
après jour la mélancolie le silence et
la joie dans cet ordre là toujours le
silence au milieu au centre la petite
robe claire du silence
voilà
notre petite parenthèse notre petit
voyage est terminé
nous allons reprendre le fil de notre
conversation vous allez pouvoir ré
ouvrir les yeux
progressivement et ce petit moment
d'intimité tombe bien parce que j'ai une
confession importante à vous faire je ne
suis pas seulement une bibliothécaire
je suis une bibliothèque r je prends
soin de vous et pour prendre soin de
vous or je n'ai pas besoin de grand
chose
j'ai juste besoin de ceux ci ceci n'est
pas un livre
ceci est une personne vivante en son
sein un coeur palpite et sucker c'est le
récit qui est niché à l'intérieur du
livre le pouvoir
un veau catoire des mots pour nous
réparer pour nous reconstruire pour être
en alignement avec nous mêmes il existe
un outil que régine detambel a
popularisé en 2015 en france dont elle
est le porte drapeau
elle a sorti un livre qui s'appelle les
livres prennent soin de nous et
effectivement les livres peuvent réparer
le monde j'en suis convaincu les livres
peuvent nous reconnecter avec cet enfant
intérieur aux cheveux grisonnants avec
cette petite fille que j'étais qui
cherchait à accomplir une mission et qui
a trouvé sa mission prendre soin des
autres
je voudrais maintenant vous inviter à
faire une expérience mais vous à lire
avec moi le texte qui va s'afficher mais
pas à le lire mécaniquement à le lire
avec une intention particulière à vous
l'offrir ou à l'offrir à des gens que
vous aimez
et pour mieux ressentir ce pouvoir des
mots sentir les mollets ressentir je
vais vous inviter à vous lever pour ceux
qui le souhaitent pour sentir cette
colonne d'air qui passe et lire ensemble
ces quelques mots
le monde t'appartient et tu appartiens
au monde
tu es libre c'est une chance tu es libre
de croire en ce que tu veux libre
d'aimer qui tu veux tu es libre d'être
aimé ou pas tu es libre de tout tenter
tu es libre même s'il ya parfois des
limites mais ses limites
tu peut les dépasser si tu le veux
vraiment parce que le monde t'appartient
et que tu appartiens au monde conquérir
sa liberté
vous pouvez vous asseoir merci conquérir
être heureux se sentir à sa place grâce
aux bibliothécaires
car oui nous sommes peut-être discret
mais en fait nous cachons des super
pouvoirs
[Applaudissements]
el rey
des super pouvoirs
le pouvoir de vous faire devenir à votre
tour les héros de votre vie et pour ça
c'est très simple il n'y a qu'à pousser
la porte d'une bibliothèque et de clamer
haut et fort aux bibliothécaires mon
bibliothécaire et le monde s'offrira à
vous dans sa plénitude
je vous en fais la promesse merci
[Applaudissements]